et en ce jour de la fête de la toussaint
à plusieurs membres de la communauté
catholique de lyon viennent prier ce
malgré le contexte qui est ensuite à
l'attentât de nice il ya quelques jours
encore à l'attack d'un prêtre orthodoxe
hier dans la capitale des gaules a pas
de dispositif sécuritaire supplémentaire
devant la paroisse du sacré coeur de
lion comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces
images écouter justement quelques
réactions des fidèles venus à célébrer
ce 1er novembre puis avoir un besoin de
se rassembler mais il n'y a pas de
crainte particulière
voilà le ce qui s'est passé
malheureusement à nice c'est pas la
première fois et voiron jeu qu'on peut
pas on peut pas vivre dans l'ombre tout
arrêter dans l' angoisse en fait de ce
qui s'est passé et de ce qui pourrait
arriver on va prier pour pour le pôle
victimes et puis voilà la vie la vie
continue de façon moins ça change eur
aujourd'hui ça fait de tout ça donc ça
fait de tout le monde donc voilà ça crée
un climat de encore est angoisse quand
même parce qu'on ne sait pas où ça va
arriver où et à qui pour quelles raisons
bon c'est ça donc
mais en même temps on se dit c'est pas
ça qui doit nous arrêter bon évidemment
il faut quand même avoir le courage
d'aller de l'avant et deux oui que en
prions que le climat se se détendent et
voilà